Yokanan walked from his house to the bus stop
at an average speed of 5 kilometers per hour.
He immediately got on the school bus
and traveled at an average speed
60 kilometers per hour until he got to school.
The total distance from his home to the school
is 35 kilometers and the whole trip took him
hour and a half.
How many miles did Yokanan walk on
and how many kilometers
did he travel by bus? This is a fascinating task.
I recommend that you pause the video
and try to think about it alone.
Let's define a few variables here.
How many kilometers did he walk on?
Let's name it with WL And how many miles
did he travel by bus?
Let's name it with B.
What do we know so far?
We know that miles ...
I can even draw it to make sure,
that we imagine it, right?
This is his home,
and then he leaves,
we are told that it is 35 kilometers from school,
that's where his school is.
I will draw a larger building, this is his school,
and we know that this distance is 35 kilometers
and we also know that it takes an hour and a half.
We know he's going
with different speeds different distances.
There is some distance to the school bus,
to the bus stop,
here is the bus stop,
and we are looking for this distance to the bus stop,
the distance that has passed on foot.
This distance is here
is W, and the rest of the distance
he went by the bus.
This whole distance is right there
will be B.
What do we know so far?
We know that the distance traveled on foot,
plus the distance traveled by bus,
will be 35 kilometers,
this is the whole distance
from home to school, that is, we know that W plus B
is equal
35 km and just one equation
we will not be able to find W and B.
But we have another condition.
We know the total time.
The total time is
hour and a half. We'll write it here.
That will be 1.5. How much time ...
How much time did he go through?
Let's write it here,
the time he spent walking.
We will divide the distance traveled.
The distance traveled is W kilometers,
divided by its speed.
The distance, divided by the speed,
will give you the time. Let's see.
Its speed is 5 kilometers per hour,
kilometers
are shortened by miles,
and if you have one on the lessons
in the denominator, it will be the same,
this will be W over 5 hours so the units coincide.
The time spent W on 5.
By the same logic
his bus time will be the distance
on the bus divided by the average speed
the school bus will be 60.
It's all in hours.
Now we can solve this system of equations.
We have two linear equations with two unknowns.
We should be able to find W and B,
to satisfy both.
How is it easiest to do it?
Let's see if I can multiply the second equation
minus 5,
this here will be minus W,
it is shortened by this W here above.
Let's do it, multiply the second equation
by ... I will switch to one color.
The above equation will be W plus B equals 35.
And the bottom equation ...
If I multiply both sides
minus 5,
i will get minus 5 by w on 5
is minus W, minus 5 B on 60.
Let's see it will be minus 5
on 60, it's minus 1/12, so it's minus B
on 12, then this will be equal to ...
1.5 by minus 5 minus 7.5.
Now we can just collect her left
right side of these two equations.
I will write it a bit clearer,
I will delete it and sort it out
a little better, I delete that.
The first equation
is W plus B equals 35,
are now better arranged and can be collected
left sides
and the right sides of the equations.
On the left, W is shortened. That's what we wanted.
B minus B on 12 or B minus twelve of B
will be 11 / 12B,
11 / 12B is equal to, let's see,
35 minus 7.5 and that's it
28, then we take another 1/2 and we get 27.5.
And because I have it here
common liver,
this is the same as 55 on 2.
Let me write it this way.
Same as 55 on 2.
And to find B, I only have to multiply
both sides on the reciprocal of this.
I will change the colors to avoid uniformity.
We multiply both sides by 12 on 11,
and we get ... These are shortened and we get,
B, I will write it with this color,
B is equal to ... Let's see, I have 12 in the numerator,
2 in the denominator, so I can
to write this as 6 and 1, then I have 55 and 11,
I can divide the two into 11, so it will be 5 and 1.
We received ... 5 in 6, B equals 30,
B is in kilometers. He has traveled 30 kilometers
by bus, B is 30 km.
The time we walked on can be easily found.
If this is 30, then the time,
during which he walked, will be 5.
It will be 5 kilometers, W,
let me write it, W equals 5 kilometers.
He walked 5 kilometers and then
has traveled 30 km by bus.